Film Courage: When that person said to you
“Hollywood will only make you more of what
you are,” what did you think in that moment?
This was 10 years ago?
John Paul Rice, Producer: No…18…19 years
ago?
Um I got a little scared because I didn’t
know what does he see in me and I knew that
I had certain family issues when I grew up
that’s kind of what got me into art (if
I can say it), creative role.
But I think also he was genuinely concerned
because he saw a decent person who had an
idealistic view and there is nothing wrong
with that.
But at the same time I think when you are
younger is just a position of not stupidity
or foolishness or maybe just ignorance because
you don’t have that experience yet to know
when you are tempted with something that you…if
you had your parent there it certainly wouldn’t
be happening.
You wouldn’t be contemplating well maybe
I should.
But in the moment you don’t realize that
when you are open and you’re sensitive,
some of that can come from trauma.
And you don’t realize that your reality
as you see it in front of you is actually
a reflection of that.
So every choice you make seems reasonable
but it may be coming from a place of fear,
it may be coming from a place of reaction
where you had to do something (this is some
of the stuff I’ve learned) where people
who are criminals (I’m just taking this
as an extreme), we see high-speed car chases
all the time, right?
We all know how that ends for the last 20
years, we see that when the car chase ends
when the cops are following you, you don’t
get away.
But time and time again people continue to
do that.
Reason being that I’ve learned in my research
and my own discovery (not that I’m a criminal)
but a lot of what we do that is irrational
to the outside is in fact rational to us because
it’s a positive behavior that warded off
something else that has been imprinted in
us that this is what gives us a positive outcome
totally unconscious of it, totally about a
set of choices.
You wake up every day and you have a set of
choices and this person over here has a different
set of choices and when he said that (I didn’t
understand the depth of it) but coming full
circle now I would give that same advice to
any young person now, I would give that same
advice now to any young person who is coming
out to LA.
Not as a caution about them but to be mindful
of yourself.
And watch how you respond, how you think,
how you act according with what is presented
in front of you.
And that sometimes takes some experience of
some very difficult decisions that you make
that at the time seemed right or maybe not
so bad but as it played out you realized “Wow
I really did screw up there.”
Or “I made a bad choice and I went against
my gut instinct.”
And I think that’s the best…I will say
this to anyone who is listening, your gut
instinct is probably your best choice.
The first thing that you think about in reaction
without knowing any information is probably
the most honest of anything as opposed to
logically talk your way through it.
I’ve had situations where I wanted certain
people do be part of our project and didn’t
realize that they didn’t want to be a part
of our project, they needed a paycheck.
Fine…that’s their right but because I
felt that I needed them I limited my choices
to that individual and attached myself to
the idea that I had to make that work as opposed
to opening up and looking at all the other
possibilities that are out there.
Now that sounds very rational and logical
but at the time it was personal, it was emotional
and I was attached to needing to have that
person validate what I was doing and win to
get it.
That’s my own personal issue.
But if I’m not exploring that and looking
at the consequences of that thinking and that
behavior and the outcomes that it gives me
then I only have one or two choices.
I’m going to be completely stubborn and
I’m going to force it.
Or all of the time and energy that I’m using
to look open and outward and look at other
people who may be able to use that may be
able to give me what I want, that they truly
want to find and find the best match and experience
has taught me that’s the best thing to do.
Film Courage: It’s not just falling prey
to temptation.
I know I’ve heard that recovery meeting
conventions are held in Las Vegas because
what better place to test your sobriety and
every trigger you have would be Las Vegas.
John: Trauma bonding!
Film Courage: Yes, but flattery.
And that’s something that as a young person,
you walk down the street and you get someone
stopping your car and saying “You would
be perfect for this…”
And especially to if you’re coming with
(let’s get really “therapist-y”) tools
that are maybe the best, that is going to
be…you are going to hear angels singing.
So if you see this enough you would be prey
to other things as well so I think flattery
can [be dangerous].
And it can happen later on and you’ll never
realize that you may never hear from that
person again and that’s something you have
to guard yourself against.
John: Yes, that’s an experience that I’ve
found.
I’ve had people sit down with me full tilt
with meetings, having watch their previous
films, having read their previous scripts
and offering a ton of things and I’m like
“This sounds great!”
And then nothing and “Oh I’m going to
introduce you to this person, that person.”
You know, I don’t know what that person’s
motivations were or not but to spend my time
getting upset about it or obsessing over it
or trying to figure out that person’s problem.
I guess it only hurts me in the end but I’ve
encountered that before early on in my career
as an actor in fact.
Film Courage: Yes, they exist!
John: You know…going out on a business meeting
and having things…we’re talking about
an era of Me Too, it happens to guys too and
it’s not being talked about.
Film Courage: Sure.
John: But there are people in Hollywood and
they have a right to do what they want but
when they cross the line you are not able
to conduct yourself as a person.
You have to sort of adjust according to them.
Now you are selling yourself into something
that is not really about you anymore.
It’s about what you do for that person.
And compliments are very easy to give.
But at the same time you have to have your
own center (your own self-worth) so that you
know that if you are dealing in business,
and you are talented, you believe in your
talent, or you have something to offer, find
someone who is looking for that.
The look and everything…I mean I do cast
all of our films.
I have seen random people and have gone up
to them and said “You have a great presence.
I’d really like to see what you look like
on camera.”
And I mean that truthfully because I love
discoveries of talent, that’s how we’ve
been able to make all of our movies with these
talented people who are not Union (most of
them are not).
And not because I’m against the Union but
just because of the cost and everything else
that we are trying to do and pay everybody
but it has more to do with being authentic
and being genuine and being professional.
And I think you can be all of those things
and still get the desired result that you
want without having to do all this other kind
of stuff which is more of like like “I’m
going to make you feel good” so I can get
something from you.
Which is all I have to offer you is the truth
according to what I see and I could be totally
wrong.
And you tell me “Hey, go ahead with yourself.
Get lost.”
But that’s your right.
All I am trying to do is say “I see something
here.
I think there is something really good here.
And I’d like to see if it would work for
what I’d like to do.”